The first answer is 3x, and our second answer is 2 plus 2 times the cube root
of 6. Great thinking for getting those two correct. Now, these were a little
bit tricky because you had to keep in mind we had cube roots. We can multiply
these two radicals together since the indexes match, so we'll get 27x cubed.
The factor of 3 appears three times underneath the radical as is the factor of
x. This means we pull out one 3 and one x to get 3x. This should also make
sense. We've seen the cube root of 27 before, and we know that's 3. And using
power divided by root, we'll have 3 divided by 3 which is x to the 1. For our
second problem, we'll distribute the cube root of 2 to each of these terms. So,
we'll have the cube root of 8 and the cube root of 48. We know the cube root of
8 is simply 2, and we can split up the cube root of 48 into cube root of 8
times 6. We use our product rule to split this up into cube root of 8 times the
cube root of 6, and simplify once again to get our final result. You might not
have always shown this step throughout your problem solving, and that's okay.
You just really want to be careful when you take cube roots of numbers. Put the
factor on the outside, and leave anything else inside the radical.